H O W S I T G O I N G A M E R S ?
iT's gAmiNg wEeK sUpReme
That's right,
We're continuing Minecraft
And Joergen is back
I had to make some adjustments-
but the sheep is back too
Hello Sheep
*Wolf bark*
epiC
Joergen, I swear to God
Stop escaping!
WHY DOEs he dO thiS?
So a lot of you were saying that I can
make like a
lasso or leash or something?
I will!
But apparently I need a Slime
So, we're gonna go find some epic Slime
No-
We're gonna go back to the pirate ship
We have a lot of epic stuff to do today,
But everyone kept saying: "Uh, thErE miGhT bE aNoTheR tREasUre mAp iN thE piRaTe shiP!"
Okay, I'll go back.
I'll go back gamers.
Gamers speak -
I listen.
Vote PewDiePie.
*Applause*
2020 gamer-
imagine a society run by gamers!
Alright, Joergen I swear to God I'm gonna go off.
Why is it white there?
Oh God damn it, it keeps happening
Alright, so if I save
and I go back, he should be there.
Yeah. Okay-
So it was a glitch!
*Angel choir*
And that was a glitch too!
Everyone was like:
"oH, hOw cAn u nOt uNdErstAnD iT wAs a gliTcH??"
Oh, I'm sorry the game that has been out for nine years,
still has basic glitches in it..?
Oh god, it's getting dark!
No, I can't do this!
*Pitched voice*   AHHH!
Hey, sugar!
*Quietly* I'll take it.
*Normal voice*   We're gonna make cake bros
Oh-
Sorry.
I think if we goooo along sea shore we should find the ship.
Oh God, CREEPERS!
It's fine gamers. I'm not afraid.
God this is a terrible idea
Oh God...
There's monsters everywhere, Joergen. but as long as you're close to me,
We'll be okay, Joergen
Okay, there it is. Found it.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god
Oh perfect, we'll put Joergen on uhh... the plateau.
Stay!
Thank you. So apparently it's really rare to find a pirate ship
In like
Above the water
...Someone said? I don't know. People can tell me anything.
But I'm supposed to look for a treasure map.
Oh God, I'm drowning!
God damn, I'm bad at this game! *laughs*
*Pitched voice*   WHAT!?
WHAAAT?
NANI DESUKA?!
WHAAAT
*Ad voice*    W H A T?
*Normal voice*   If there's a treasure map on this boat
I'll find it
So why can't I not breathe under water?
The easiest way to find it is maybe going down....?
I CAN'T BREATHE THAT LONG! >:(
I'm not a fish!
Where is-
That- I bet you guys are trolling me again.
God, this is taking forever.
Come on, It's so obvious that that was it.
It's the only part that goes down, too.
Alright, after mining uh, the whole thing all night
I have deduced that there is no...
...treasure map.
ThAnKs gAmErS
-For nothing!-
It's fine we have other stuff to do.
It doesn't matter.
It wasn't even important.
Let's get out of this place, Joergen.
Whoa!
Dolphins, that's EPIC!
Hey sheep, we're back.
Wow. What an adventure.
Go in Joergen.
Go in.
Thank you.
♫ I got the horses in the back ♫
Dark wood. How-
Where did he?!
Oh God it happened again.
Alright.
We may not have gotten a treasure map,
But at least we got a dark door
*Laughs*
Yeah, look at that beautiful carpet. It looks so nice now, I know, I know I know.
Well, well, well, okay.
Step 2. Get Gucci pants 👖
Alright, who's the Gucci man?
You're the Gucci man?
Why?
By the way, I might steal that.
Looking for a Gucci guy.
WHERE'S THE GUCCI GUY??
God dammit, this is such a failure
What are you doing?
Maybe I give him stuff
I hate them-
I want them to die
They're gonna pay for this.
I can make leather horse armor?
𝔀𝓱𝓐𝓐𝓐𝓐𝓐𝓐𝓣?
*Ad*   You never played Tuber Simulat-
I can make armor for - oh my god, I can make armor,
For
For Joergen!!!
Joergen!
Look, I have a present for you
Oh, you're dark at night?
Let's lit you up.
Cyoot! Shut up, shut up, everyone quiet
Joergen, this is a special moment:
You are getting leather armor.
*Gasp*   You look so fancy, dude. Oh my god!
*Pitched voice*   That's awesome! I love him!
Let's go, good night.
Okay, Joergen; Wish me good luck.
We're going to the Nether.
Cuz everyone said there's a...
secret achievement if you sleep in the Nether.
Why would anyone do that?
Oh god, this place is so creepy dude.
Why on earth would I sleep here?
This is awful.
Alright, fine. We'll make a lil'
Nether-Realm house. How about that?
It's gonna be so cute
Oh god, I'm scared
All right, good night gamers-
AAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!
My own audience..
My own supporters, can you believe this?? Scared me dude.
I dunno what I was expecting.. but not
God dammit
*Laugh cry*
My house! Noo.
Oh my god..
God- aah..
Damn yooouuuuu!
Give me back my stuff dudeee.
If I don't get back my diamond pickaxe..
we're through, okay? I'm done.
I deserve better than this
My house blew up!
Are you kidding me?
God dammit, where is it?
I got like half my stuff, dude.
Help me look pig people!
fucking useless
Can I ge-- how do I--
Oh, I can chop away the flames.
There we go... go away
Cool.
I'm glad I brought back gaming week to get epically trolled
..And lose half my stuff
"sLeEp iN thE nEthEr fEliX"
niniNInINininNiNinini
I missed - I lost my pants
Do you feel good about yourself?
What's a block of quartz?
It looks pretty, I like it.
God dammit I lost my shield, too.
So, someone said I can actually go to the Nether realm with Joergen.
I just have to, like- I want to see if that's possible.
It seems like a terrible idea.
Ahhh! Joergen is drowning
What? No, Joergen went through!
Joergen, come back! come back!
Come baaaack!
God dammit.
God dammit! Joergen,
you crazy!
Alright.
So does the compass work here?
No, it doesn't. Grrrreat.
On second thought, no!
The hell?
I gotta teleport Joergen.
No-!
*Jorgen dying*
Joergen, get out! Get out!
nOOOOOOOOOOO! ! ! !
NOOOOO!!!! NOOOO
no..
no...
*pewds crying..*
no..
It was here a second ago...
maybe he went through to the other side..
No
No, I'm not crying..
Shut up. You are.
Oh my god..
He left us way too soon..
Joergen was like a father to me...
I loved him like my son..
You never know when the ones that love you are gonna leave you..
*Sad music plays*
I never thought this day would come..
He left us too soon..
Rest in peace Joergen
Rest in peace
If I die, fine, I can respawn
Joergen can't respawn.
I have to get Joergen number two.
Now, of course-
Now, of course there can only be one Joergen
But there is Jorgen number two
Here you go, Joergen
Have it all
Okay
Hopefully this one
hopefully Joergen the second won't be such an asshole
Feel like I just bought myself a new pet..
it will never be the same,
I'm still hurting
Wait, there's one thing I wanna do.
Here you go, Joergen..
He loved melons..
I'll plant the tree for Joergen..
I'll plant as many trees...
Alright
Things happen, we must move on.
We have other things to do.
Okay?
We're gonna kill the Ender Dragon..
Let's go, Joergen.
Why does Joergen have more life?
Joergen the second.
Oh!
I've never been in the desert before.
*Gasp* There's bunnies!
There's freaking bunnies??
Can I put them in the bucket?
Damn it
You're back, buddy.
What's up?
Hellooo?
What are you doing in the the desert?
Can you go in the bucket?
What? where did you go?
Mysterious.
Alright, I'm gonna have to kill some bunnies.
I'm sorry, look away children
*Demonic music plays*
Look away children, I'm sorry.
Uhhh!
Oohh!
Oh, he's back. What the hell?
Wha--
Wow, this place is cool. [sure is]
Whoa, another house?
What is that?
It's got a creeper face on it.
Whaaat?
Whoa!
What is this?
Whoa (3)
Whoa! (4)
Whoa (5)
Whoa! (6)
Whaat?
My god minecraft,
If Joergen could see this he'd be freaking out.
Okay, he better not run away this time.
*Whispering*   Whoa (7)
That's really deep. (That's what he said)
Oh, it goes up as well.
That's so cool!
How do I go down there?
I'm scared
Ok, here we go.
Whoa (8)
Oh, no! Oh, no!
I set off a bomb didn't I?
...
Mmmmmmm
Dammit!
Dammit!!
*sulks in swedish*
THIS EPISODE SUCKS!!
*moaning*
miiiiiinecraaaaaaft
♫ If I could take it all away ♫
♫ If I can doooo whaat they say ♫
Why did I do that?
I could have got - I bet there was like awesome stuff in the-
DAMIIIITTTTT
Some murderers..
It's my evil arc.. Beginning
alright, if anything else happens
𝕀𝕄. 𝔾𝕆ℕℕ𝔸. 𝔹𝔼. 𝕍𝔼ℝ𝕐. 𝔸ℕ𝔾ℝ𝕐.
What the freaking that dude?
What the hell?
Wha??
wOW~
Whoa (9)
Whoa (10)
Whoa (11)
Whoa (12)
I'm just confused by everything.
First of all, we need to get Joergen the second back.
And second of all
Oh god, what a day!
"You ever had a bad day in Minecraft?"
*Pewds chuckles*
Never had a bad day? well, imagine having a bad day in Minecraft. Okay?
Okay, I see Joergen.
This good-
I thought this was a kids game.
Okay?
Why are there actual traps in there? Oh, I got you now
Oh, I got you now!
Oh I got you now!!
Oh!!! I actually got him!
Oh no, I'm sorry
My trusty horse, Joergen the second, my man
*Pewds mimicking Jorgens voice*   I missed you Poods
Thanks,
ᴵ ᵍᵘᵉˢˢ
Now we're gonna need a lot of sand.
Cuz we gotta go down again.
*whispers*   God dammit.
There better not be any more traps in here.
Oh my gawd
Ahh!
Oh god..
Of course, there's a creeper there as well
What are you doing? Go away!
Ah my god
Guys, I am having a bad day. Okay
You're not going after me?
Oh my- ohh
aaaaah
mmmmmmmm
MMmmmMMMMmmmm
AAAAAAAA
AaahHHHHhhh
sTop SToP!!
Stoooaaaaaaaaap *pewds crying*
*pewds scream of frustration, grief, hopelessness*
Alright, we keep on gaming. Its gaming week...
It's gaming week
*laughs in pain*
And so he kept walking
with no armor
no skill
and no hope.
He just wants Joergen back
...And all his stuff too would be great
Play Minecraft they said, sleep in the Nether they said
You can enter there with your horse they said
I can never trust anyone ever again
Not even myself
At least Joergen the second actually is cool.
Here we go again.
I'm getting my stuff.
I don't care.
I'm getting my stuff
Maybe...
Whoa (13)
What a cool room
Maybe.
Surely they're gone now, right?
Look at the - damage
Alright, if I find like a sword, or anything,  I'll take it.
I see stuff down there.
Oh my god, that's my stuff.
That's literally my stuff.
-awgodawgodawgod-  This is good.
-awgod-
This is just the first stuff.
He drop the bow.
Come on, come on, come on surely
My diamond pickaxe is here, right?
Look at this explosion dude.
You can-
*Smacking sounds*
All gone
Cool.
Let's never do that again
Epicc.
Did you find the treasure?
Yes.
What did it cost?
Everything.
Okay.
Okay,
Joergen and Pewds for more adventures -
I'm genuinely upset..
over Minecraft.
*laughs in pain*
oh godd..
what is happen?
Is that another one? Or the same one?
Okay..
No, it's the same one.
Is that another shipwreck??
It is, isn't it?
Damn it's far.
Joergen, will you be good?
It's how we hunt fishes in Sweden
Hi-yah!
Ohh my god!! It worked!
Okay,
we're going to the--
pirate thing and maybe we finally get some good news this episode.
God frickin damn it.
There better be epic treasure--
Oh, this one looks bigger.
*Gasp* I see a treasure.
Okay. Okay.
Oh, what is this?
Whoa (14)
Looks like an air hole.
Cool, paper.
Hey, you want some paper?
Here you go, Felix
Oh! There's another one
*gasp*
PoTatOeS!
Oh! another one!
Whoa (15)
Okay!
Rich boy
Rich boy 😎😎😎
I could get Gucci pants
Ow, ow, ow!
Okay epic.
Joergen, it was awesome!  *chuccles*
Ahh, my god
Burried-- *Gasps*
We found a treasure map!
Hu-oh?
What do I do with it?
What do I do with buried treasure map?
Sun is setting.
Let's go back home, Joergen..
It's been an adventure.
Jorgen the second..
Alright, time to go to sleep.
I'll dream of Jorgen the first...
..Forever
One thing that I'm curious about is...
Yeah, I hope you're dying
What happens if--
--you build another Nether portal in the Nether realm
Question mark ?
So let's explore that question
Okay, I've never actually done this.
How do I do it??
Uhh?
What?
Alright, gamers..
*𝐞𝐩𝐢𝐜𝐜 𝐦𝐮𝐬𝐢𝐜 𝐩𝐥𝐚𝐲𝐬*    Here we go!
Wohoohoo!!
Oooohh shiiiihehehehe!!
hehehEhEhEeehEEE!!
Oh, yeah!!
Gaming time!
Hey, someone's shooting me?
This is my gaming time.
If I remember correctly. I had obsidian down here.
Yup, there it is.
Just be careful
Cuz there's freaking lava everywhere.
This is always fun.
What the hell is that?
It's a bat
Dumb bat
HAhahAhAhAah
I would never make that mistake.
Okay, we have ten
All we need baby.
Now, if we enter..
the Nether.
What up pig
Now let's say we walk... a bit..
..further
God it's so hard to walk in there.
Where would I go?
You guys have nothing better to do?
Jesus Christ, dude.
Oh my god
*whispers*    Ah, im so scared
Fine, let's just build a bridge.
Life gives you lemons--
--build bridges over them.
So what is that down there? Is that worth mining?
I wish I knew..
Maybe I'll explode out of nowhere?
--or we can just clog this.
*Ghast cries in a not so far distant*
What's that sound??
*Ghast cries gets louder*
God, I hate that sound..
I think we can stop this as well.
Oh yeahhh! No more lava!
Don't worry piggies, I won't charge ya
Okay..
What is this?
Nande kore?
Whoa (16)
This looks cool!
Ow!!
Alright, don't walk on them.
Got it.
I can hold them--
--but I can't walk on 'em.
I mean I guess it makes sense. They're hot
Dude, there's so many!
Uh, what's happening with the music??
𝐻𝑒𝓁𝓁𝑜?
Little too epic for my taste, thank you.
Alright, alright, you can calm down, Minecraft.
Magma block?
𝕆𝕜𝕒𝕪.
𝔼𝕡𝕚𝕔
ᴡʜʏ ᴅᴏ ɪ ꜰᴇᴇʟ ʟɪᴋᴇ ᴍʏ ᴡʜᴏʟᴇ ʟɪꜰᴇ ɪꜱ ꜰʟᴀꜱʜɪɴɢ ᴛʜʀᴏᴜɢʜ ᴍʏ ᴇʏᴇꜱ?
𝘩𝘰𝘭𝘺,
𝘮𝘰𝘭𝘺,
𝘴𝘴𝘴𝘴𝘴𝘴𝘴𝘴 --
𝘮𝘢𝘤𝘢𝘳𝘰𝘯𝘪,
𝘱𝘦𝘱𝘱𝘦𝘳𝘰𝘯𝘪.
This better not kill me,
I'm gonna be pissed.
Okay.
Let's go.
whAt's goNNa haPPEn?
ι ∂ση'т кησω!
That's the joy of Minecraft.
So, it does take me to another place.
uHHHHhhhhhhhhhhmm?
Whaat?
d0nKEYs?
there's fucking llamas in this game, dude?
they're so cute
Aaaaaaaaa!!!
No, take me back to Netherland!
Why is there underwater things there?
Uhhhhhh...
Helloooooo?
What??
Is it a glitch?
Oh what?
Uh okay, that's scary.
Magma blocks.
Oh god! They're slurping!
That's so confusing--
--So those lit up?
lLaMa
tHEsE ArE lLaMaS
There is fricken lla--
--don't explode my llamas
--𝕀 𝕨𝕚𝕝𝕝 𝕜𝕚𝕝𝕝 𝕪𝕠𝕦
Oh, the shield can tank them?
Oh, they talk, they make noises!
gUnPoWdEr?
Frick Frick Frick Frick --
--They're so cute
I wanna take you home.
Oh my god, you're so adorable.
Oh my god, they're still coming--
This one's got a bow dude!
It's a swamp monster?
These guys are strong dude.
Ｉ  ｗａｎｔ  ｔｈｅ  ｌｌａｍａ
What do they eat?
So is there any way I can breathe underwater easier?
Ooh
What is this?
I don't know.
There better not be traps, that's all I know.
What is this?
Oh, there's a chest
Oh god --
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up
Bwooh
There better not be sharks in this game
then I'm quitting
Alright then,
I just want the chest
Are you kidding me?
That's it?
Oh!
It's his
What?
blue ice?
So if I kill him,
can I steal his llamas?
Cuz I will do it.
DON'T YOU SPIT ON ME!!
okay, I see a lot more stuff to explore
BUT
I'm gonna have to end the episode here guys
whooooo!!
Because I need the comments to help me
ACTUALLY
I CAN'T TRUST YOU
Smash Like! And I'll see you guys
next time
BYE
*AD* 𝓦𝓞𝓣
You never played Tuber simulator??? :0
*Intense effects* PPPPPFFFFFSSHHHHH
You know, it's fun right?
I'm not supposed to give my Ⓞⓟⓘⓝⓘⓞⓝ
But give it a try~ and then
you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet. Okay
I'll cut you a deal~ ( ͡◉ ͜ʖ ͡◉)
The game is available for
𝓕𝓡𝓔𝓔
And that's a 𝓖𝓻𝓮𝓪𝓽  𝓹𝓻𝓲𝓬𝓮!
(bo dee dum de dum de dum dum)